[Music]
one of the reasons why we're in the mess
we're in and the rise of populism
is because too many politicians don't
look at the evidence and too many
politicians
are not being honest with the british
people so let's have a look at the
evidence shall we
the evidence a large part of which i've
seen
because you managed i managed to get the
government to disclose
documents which the cabinet had seen
about and the
impact and the effect of a no deal
brexit
and also of course the government
through its civil servants this is a
brexit government
so it thinks brexit is okay and good
it got the civil service to look at all
the different models
for brexit michael and the
civil servants who i like to think we
would all agree are impartial
get on do their job in a professional
way
found that whichever way you do brexit
it will reduce the future prosperity of
our country and in particular
if we leave without a deal and of course
we
were actually promised that we wouldn't
leave without a deal in fact
leave told us we won't leave until a
deal has been done
so the evidence is that the worst form
of brexit
is to crash out without a deal so why
can't politicians
be honest about that and actually
to his credit ladies and gentlemen jacob
rees-mogg
he was he was honest he said
it could take up to 50 years
before we felt the benefits of brexit
i can tell you my constituents in broxto
weren't told that and i can also tell
you
about the customs union and the single
market they talked of nothing else in
the pubs and cafes in brock's though
i'm i'm glad to hear we'll be spending
so much time
were the same scare stories we heard
during the referendum campaign when we
were towed by the same people
that a vote for brexit not brexit but a
vape for brexit
would lead to an immediate recession we
were told an immediate need for an
emergency budget
none of those things happened yes it was
i'm going to come to you in a minute
and and here we are here we are nearly
three years later
with record low unemployment with a
record number of people in jobs
those those are the facts well you can
well i can tell you those people who are
in work wouldn't boo
they there's those those children
those children who no longer grow up in
workless hotels
wouldn't boo they would they would be
jolly pleased that we have
like record employment and and and
record low unemployment
and i heard anna say during the
referendum campaign
on any questions she talks about
evidence
i had anna say that if we left the
european union her exact words i write
them down at the time
if we leave the european our trade with
europe
would dwindle to almost nothing that was
a stupid thing
and she for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of art and ideas at iai tv
you